openc and nfts openc a peer-to-peer
marketplace for nfts has seen explosive
growth in the last eight months or so
transactions have soared from eight
million dollars in january of this year
to already 2.3 billion dollars in august
from 8 million in january to 2.3 billion
dollars in august of this year
absolutely nuts open c takes 2.5 fee of
each transaction that happens on the
platform helping the platform grow
along with the nft ecosystem when you
think of a new industry being created
one of the best ways to invest in it is
to simply invest in infrastructure that
benefits from the overall market growing
regardless of what of the individual
websites products etc ends up winning so
marketplace is a great way to do that it
was founded only in 2017 the company is
not that old about four years old and in
july they raised a hundred million
dollars with a valuation of 1.5 billion
dollars in 2018 the transaction the
total transaction volume in 2018 was 437
thousand dollars
yes i just said that in 2018 they did
437 000 in transactions in 2019 they did
8 million in 2020 they did 24 million
and they just did 2.3 billion already in
the month of august absolute
nuts growth for this platform we have
from dap radar a spokesperson who says
quote what we have seen are a few nft
collections popping up in the last few
weeks that have been very successful at
launch and sold out that activity has
been filtered over to open c where
buyers look to flip their nfts for a
higher price a lot of this reminds me of
what we see with supreme and flip
culture or sneakers etc people buying
things on launch where there's a quick
sell out of them then turning around and
selling to those who didn't get it for a
higher price flip culture next we have
nft sales volume hitting a record high
in q2 this is only the q2 numbers we did
not get to q3 yet because not over
quarterly non-fungible token sales
volumes across multiple blockchains in
u.s dollars topping 1.24 billion in q2
huge growth in the beginning of this
year we then also have the nft
sales on openc specifically as you can
see that is pretty impressive growth
literally august september october
november december you can't even see
how much sales they did on the chart
when august is so absurd and that hasn't
even crossed 2 billion yet as of the
time of that specific chart now we're
over 2.3 billion for the month and then
lastly you can see with google search
terms open c itself spiking incredibly
for those looking for the platform and
so nfts are interesting for two reasons
one
they end up being a new way to monetize
intellectual property whether we were
talking about things like nba topshop or
we're talking about art or any of the
other nft projects that have been
created you can see that let's take the
nba what does the nba do they take their
intellectual property they package it up
and they sell it to cable networks and
that is where you see the nba on
television joe can tell us the details
of how much money they actually make
second is you'll see them take the logo
or players or the team names etc and
they will put them on all sorts of
physical products you'll see them do
things like t-shirts headbands posters
bobble heads etc they're creating
memorabilia they're creating
collectibles then you'll also see the
nba take intellectual property and
create digital media or digital products
that they are then able to sell to the
fans as well could be your favorite team
it could be your favorite player it
could be the league itself so when you
look at the intellectual property
options they have to monetize it's
either sell it to the cable networks as
a package for the entire season or for
certain types of games or the playoffs
or the nba finals then they have
physical products and then they have
digital products but now what we saw
with nba top shot is they essentially
were able to take the
actual iep the intellectual property the
mba they were able to take highlights
they were unbundling rather than by the
nba finals or rather than buy the
playoffs or rather than buy the entire
regular season or games on every
saturday etc what you're able to do is
you're actually able to buy one
individual highlight now what they did
was by unbundling that intellectual
property package and then selling it to
an open market a free market kind of an
open system they were able to get a
market dynamic a market pricing of those
assets now as you would expect any time
you take an asset you unbundle it and
you expose it to the free market the
price is likely to go up it in one hand
showed that the nba was actually selling
their intellectual property for too
little because the entire package of a
season or the finals or the playoffs was
going for much much less than all of the
uh total value of the individual parts
but with that also said we've seen nba
top shot go from literally hundreds of
millions of dollars of volume to in july
they only did or in the last 30 days or
so they only did about 30 million
dollars in total transaction volume and
so what that tells you is that people
got really excited it exploded in value
it's come down quite a bit i'm not
worried about individual projects when
we think about this intellectual
property whether mba top shot wins or
loses is not something that i spend a
lot of time thinking about i hope that
the team behind it ends up being
successful but it's not about one
individual thing it's more about the
mechanism to me so then when you look at
something like crypto punks or board ape
yacht club what you start to realize is
that is people simply creating some
version of status no different than
supreme putting their logo on top of a
skateboard a bag a t-shirt etc or
somebody like gucci doing the exact same
now they are simply doing this for
digital goods and they're selling it to
young people for the most part who are
digital natives they want some sort of
status symbol in the digital realm now
with that said there are two key things
that i do think are quite misleading
about this industry one where it gets
built does not matter what i mean by
that is there are a ton of different
smart contract platforms and everyone is
in some way saying oh this is going to
be the winner we've seen things like
ethereum but we've also seen things like
flow which are nft specific blockchains
everyone is trying to figure out where
it's going to be built i personally
don't think that anyone actually cares
who's on the buyer end of these
transactions where it's being built that
leads me to my second point the reason
why they don't care is because
decentralization does not matter for the
most part in these systems what do i
mean by that i mean that when you look
at who is actually selling any sort of
scarce good in the legacy world they're
all centralized
hierarchical structures so everyone from
gucci to supreme to the nba etc they're
all centralized entities with
hierarchical structures decentralization
doesn't matter and in fact in some cases
decentralization would actually be more
difficult to execute those business
plans and those product sales when we
move to the digital realm
decentralization for the most part does
not matter it does not matter that
nobody is able to steal your system off
of a blockchain it does not matter that
nobody is able to
create more nfts a perfect example board
ape yacht club ten thousand of these
things they then created a mutant
version which is another ten thousand
does that dilute the originals or does
that simply create a whole new franchise
if you are a new intellectual property
people are debating i don't have an
answer but it's interesting to see and
so when you start to understand that
decentralization might not matter nearly
as much as people would have thought it
was it would and two that the end buyer
doesn't actually care what blockchain
these things are actually built on what
you find is that ultimately people
simply want three things they want
intellectual property that they think is
valuable regardless of whether i my
brothers or anybody else thinks it's
valuable or not ultimately just like art
value is derived by the people in the
transaction if one person believes that
they can sell something to another
person who believes that it has value
therefore that is a free market
determining value that is not for anyone
else to judge you simply can make a
decision as well from an investment
standpoint if you think that something
has value and you want to buy it and you
think it will appreciate over a long
period of time that is your right to do
it also you are making an investment
decision when somebody goes to sell
something that you think does not have
value and you choose not to buy it that
is the free market going through and
getting the perspective of multiple
players so ultimately when you have
decentralization not mattering as much
and people not caring about the
underlying blockchain what you get is
you get a recreation of the legacy
system in this digital world i actually
think that's fantastic as we see through
things like openc and others what you
start to understand is that we are
watching digital scarcity which is now
possible in the digital world you can
prove that there is actual digital
scarcity by having this public ledger
where you can actually see what the
assets are who has handled them and you
can actually check any sort of
authenticity serial numbers etc and then
you can say to yourself do i find this
valuable there's obviously billions and
billions of dollars of sales some people
will argue that that is ultimately going
to be bad investment decisions others
will argue that crypto punks will be
worth 10 20 50 100 million dollars in
the future i don't know but ultimately i
do know that the market is going to
decide and so it's worth paying
attention to but as in most markets
regardless of if you think crypto punks
board ape yacht club nba top shot or
name your favorite nft project is going
to end up being successful or not the
people who end up making a ton of money
through these boom cycles are the
infrastructure and openc is doing a
great job of that what's up guys bang
bang a bunch of you want to bring that
trillionaire energy every day and if you
want to do it in your financial life go
use sofi so fi is our exclusive sponsor
because we think they've got a great
piece of software that'll help you
accomplish your financial dreams go to
sofi.com today to get started you can
invest in everything from etfs to
individual stocks to cryptocurrencies to
ipos and they even have an automated and
best function head on over to sofi.com
today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]